bonsoir jean pierre albertini merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on imagine
voilà que le moment est solennel
compliqué à la veille de ce procès dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous
bien ces procès à réutilisant après le
crime donc on a eu le temps de
s'habituer à notre
situation de familles de victimes et
ce procès donc est un procès pénal est
donc ce que l'on attend c'est que les
pelles qui seront infligées seront à la
hauteur du crime et est ce qu'on espère
surtout c'est que dans celle mois seront
prononcées si en tout cas seront
effectives effectué et nora concis parce
que si l'on reprend tous les assassins
du bataclan ils étaient tous connus de
la police fichés
le premier est sous contrôle judiciaire
qui ne respectaient pas donc ce que je
peux espérer au minimum c'est que ce
procès pénal
appliquent des sanctions qui seront
effectivement réalisé
aujourd'hui ces condamnations elle
concerne on imagine évidemment ça
d'abdeslam qui est le seul rescapé aussi
quelques complices mais vous le disiez
il ya eu certains dysfonctionnements
peut-être parce qu'ils étaient connus
ces assassins de l'êta aujourd'hui ce
sont des condamnations mais aussi une
reconnaissance de certaines familles
c'est bien cela
oui je crois que les études qui ont été
faites et notamment l' enquête
parlementaire qui a été réalisé en 2016
on montre effectivement des failles dans
le renseignement
des failles aussi dans le la ligne
politique la ligne judiciaire et
j'espère que ce procès permettra au
moins de démonter et de démontrer tout
ce qui a dysfonctionné et surtout pour
empêcher que les chose de semblable se
reproduise
aujourd'hui on le disait un donc le seul
rescapé du commando du 13 novembre ces
salles abdeslam il est resté
désespérément muet pendant toute
l'instruction aujourd'hui vous vous
attendez quelque chose de cet homme des
explications
non honnêtement il restait multi de jeu
en sisal et je ne pense pas qu'il va
soudain se déclarer c'est en fait c'est
un lâche je pense qu'il n'a pas activé
sa son gilet de songer des explosifs
alors on dit qu'il y avait un
dysfonctionnement vont peut-être mais en
fait c'est un large et puis tous ses
complices se sont aussi des gens qui ont
travaillé pendant une année pour des
assassinats bien prémédité donc ce sont
tous des coupables à des niveaux bien
sûr différent et l'instruction je pense
à tulle démontrer et donc je pense que
lors de ce procès du japon dans des
choses intéressantes pendant les huit
mois puisque dans ces huit mois il ya
seulement un mois qui est dévolue aux
témoignages des victimes donc laisser
les autres mois sont dévolues à
l'explication de tout ce qui a été
découvert à travers l'instruction
aujourd'hui justement vous offre deux
victimes mais également les les
survivants ce sont ces réponses que vous
attendez ces explications qui seront
évoqués pendant ces sept tonnes moi de
savoir ce qui s'est passé
oui je pense qu'au delà de l'enjeu
classique les procès je judiciaire des
procès pénaux je pense qu'effectivement
le deuxième enjeu c'est de connaître le
fonctionnement de ces réseaux leur
financement la manière dont les
assassins se sont promenés à l'intérieur
et l'extérieur de l'espace schengen dont
tous ces mécaniques qui sont démontés et
qui normalement devrait empêcher que
cela se reproduise
et puis bien sûr je pense qu'on pourra
pas éviter de comptes d'essayer de
comprendre au moins quels sont les
idéologies sous jacente qui ont permis à
des jeunes qui étaient quand même
qui vivait en europe et qui avait la
chance d'être dans des pays
démocratiques en paix à des jeunes qui
rose et tué lâchement des jeunes de la
même génération donc je pense qu'au delà
des peines et au delà des explications
je pense qu'il y aura une explicitation
de de lait biologique a permis cela
parce que pour nous ce sont des
assassins mais de leur côté ce sont
presque des héros
vous disiez tout à l'heure pour que ça
ne se reproduise pas aujourd'hui
clairement six ans
après vous estimez qu'il ya eu tout de
même un progrès ce genre d'attentât on
voit en france on peut encore arriver
alors je pense est au minimum il y a eu
une prise de conscience du danger
je pense qu'en 2015 la menace n'était
pas évalué à sa juste mesure et qui a eu
de sous-estimation de la menace
notamment par les élites et et les
personnes qui dirigeait le pays à
l'époque donc une sous-estimation un v10
sans doute
mais la méthode cauet ne marche pas dans
ce genre de deux domaines donc je pense
effectivement qu'il ya eu les
consciences et au delà vers les
consciences il y a eu quand même des
améliorations
des procédures et et et des lois
concernant le cas le terrorisme jean
pierre albertini est ce que vous allez
vous même assister à ce procès si oui
est ce qu'il y à une appréhension à
revivre tous ces moments oui bien sûr
évidemment je vais bien sûr assisté au
possible peut-être pas tous les jours
puisque il a été décidé qu'il y aurait
une web radio qui permettrait de suivre
en permanence
même depuis chez soi les audiences avec
un léger décalage dans le temps
et de miège pas de décalage donc j'irai
pour les audiences qui me paraît très
importante je sais que l'ancien
président de la république ancien
ministre de l'intérieur l'ancien premier
ministre vont témoigner
je pense qu'il y aura des jours qui
seront importants et au delà il peut y
avoir des evènement au port des huit
mois qu'ils feront que ce procès pendant
une dimension encore plus importante que
ce pour lui donne aujourd'hui vous
pensez à quels événements
par définition les évènements inattendus
de ne sont pas connues
toutes sortes d'événements des
événements politiques des événements
militaires ou des événements
sécuritaires tout est possible un procès
c'est un tel organe bilan donc tout est
possible et ça dure huit mois et ses
tueurs en plus une année préélectorale
donc beaucoup d'enjeu seront
évalués au travers de ce procès qui
évidemment est un procès pour nous un
procès d' assassin mais comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure qui est pas revu
par d'autres yeux
une vitrine pour certaines idéologies
qui fait merci beaucoup en tout cas jean
pierre albertini un pardon de stéphane
assassiné au bataclan en 2015 merci
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir accepté
notre interview ce soir et bon courage
merci